- Speaking of crimes on Tinder,
the Toronto Sun reports a
woman recently found out
that it violates Tinder law to appear as a
dot, dot, dot,
clown.
Jess Harkin got kicked off the app
for posing in clown makeup.
The thing is she's a professional clown
and her real name,
or no, her clown name is Kazoo,
and she just wanted to find love
and maybe another clown out there
to match up with,
and Tinder claim that she was
violating their terms of use.
I cannot believe that you
can be a Tinder Swindler,
but not a clown.
- Yeah.
(Ross laughs)
- She appealed and got
her per profile back.
- So she showed herself
in her outfit for work.
If she was a chef,
and showed her in a chef hat, right?
This is what, this is who she is.
She's a clown.
- And honestly,
aren't there people who do
up their Instagram so much,
with so much makeup
that it's like a clown.
It's just that their
face is not a clown face.
- That's some good shade.
That's some good shade Deborah Norville.
That is, yes.
(audience applauds)
'Cause some of the people
be wearing too much makeup.
- I'm just like, where
is the line anymore?
You can't be a clown on Tinder?
- Mm-hm. Would you date a clown?
(audience laughs)
- I think I have.
- [Ross] Yeah. (laughs)
(audience applauds)
- You're up now, Ross.
- I think you have.
(audience applauds)
All right.
(laughs) Next up.
I love this, so anybody here
ever have trouble getting online?
Like your Internet's out or something?
We've all been there.
Well, a French dad is
in some hot water now
for trying to keep his
kids off the internet.
The New York Post reports
he set up a scrambler
to block Wi-Fi in his house,
from midnight to 3:00 AM,
to keep his kids from
scrolling the night away,
which sounds sort of smart, right?
But the problem is, it worked,
but a little too well,
'cause it blocked the
internet for the entire town.
(audience reacts)
Yes.
Not only that, several
surrounding towns as well.
And now, he reportedly faces fines
and even six months in
prison if he's found guilty.
I mean it started out
kind of smart, you know,
"My kids staying up late scrolling,
so let me turn the internet off",
except you know, oops.
(audience laughs)
- Mm-hm.
- I love him.
If I could stop my kids
from doom scrolling
from midnight till 3:00
AM, I would totally do so.
- Well, you can, yeah.
- Can I just say something?
- Please?
- What?
- It is against the law.
- Oh, right, okay.
- It is against the law in France.
It is against the law in America.
- Mm-hm.
- It is against the law
to use a jamming device
to stop the reception of cellular service.
Here's how you stop the
kids from doom scrolling.
This is the phone, (taps
phone) you take it.
You take it away
from the children.
- Oh, that's easier.
(audience applauds)
- It's so much easier
and guarantees it will
not land you in jail.
- Thank you.
- Clearly.
All right, Deborah, what's next?
- Well, speaking of jail,
this is a bear that needs to be in jail.
CNN is reporting there's a big, giant bear
that is breaking into houses
in Lake Tahoe, California.
He is apparently very hungry
and he has-
(audience gasp)
he's obviously eaten a lot.
His nickname is "Hank the Tank",
estimated to run at around, oh 500 pounds.
He's been accused of breaking
into at least 28 homes.
But now there's new evidence that says
that Hank actually might
not be a solo operator.
There's DNA evidence,
you can speculate what that might be,
that shows that there may be
a whole bunch of bears
responsible for the break ins
and local residents say,
"He just kind of sits there and eats.
He doesn't attack.
He doesn't growl.
He doesn't make ugly faces, he just eats."
Hank the Tank, on the loose.
- Oh wow.
- What do we do?
- I love Hank.
I think he's just, you know
looking for Goldilocks,
just for payback.
(audience laughs)
You know what I mean?
House, by house, by
house, trying to find her.
- What if this is like a
crazy, new sadistic diet
for keeping you...
The guy who took all the internet away,
so his kids wouldn't be up.
From midnight to 3:00 AM, I
can go to the refrigerator
and do some real damage.
And if I thought there
was a 500 pound bear
in the kitchen, I might think twice.
- [Ross] Yeah.
- So maybe we should just all imagine
that Hank the Tank is
hanging out in our kitchen,
right when we wanna go and self-sabotage.
- Yes, your thighs will appreciate it.
- Yes!
- Best diet ever.
(audience applauds)
- New diet alert.
There's a bear in your kitchen.
(bright music)